würden sie Waffen liefern an die Ukraine
lukasten keiner von uns
wiedersehen auch sie noch ich können
sagen ob Waffenlieferung zu einem Sieg
führen zu einem Frieden führen oder ob
sie mich nicht vertagen
keiner kann sagen dass das am Ende
wirklich zu einem zu einem Sieg oder zu
dem
gewünschten Ergebnis zumindest für das
können wir verbindlich doch man kann
aber umgekehrt argumentieren wenn die
Ukraine keine Waffen erhielte oder
erhalten hätte wäre sie längst zerfallen
mehr tun das ist ja der Punkt die
Zurückhaltung der Bundesregierung hat ja
nicht dazu geführt dass Russland sich
zurückgenommen hat sondern zwischen Juli
und Dezember wo wir keine Panzer
geliefert haben über 30.000 sind
Menschen in Kellern umgebracht worden
sind zivile Ziele zerstört worden kaum
militärische sind Kinder entführt worden
10000 das Verleugnen sie damit und wir
müssen diese Waffen liefern damit die
Ukraine in der Lage ist ihre Grenzen
wieder hier die Unterstellung das zu
verleugnen die sollten Sie bitte
zurücknehmen
ist die Bundes
das falsche Sprache noch mal die Frage
Lukas wie würden sie es machen
also sozusagen prinzipiell immer dagegen
zu sein ist ja noch kein Programm das
ist auch nicht Politik gestalten wie
würden sie es machen wie würden Sie zum
Beispiel mit der Tatsache dass Russland
die Ukraine überfallen wie würden Sie
damit umgehen würden sie Waffen liefern
wenn sie keine Waffen liefern und sie
sagen dass sie da mal machen und dann
besteht Putin im Zweifel morgen wirklich
vor Moldau oder
von der Grenze Polens wir würden sie es
machen also wenn wenn diese Bedrohung
durch die Russische Föderation als
solche gesehen wird dann muss natürlich
auch müssen verantwortliche Staaten auch
dafür sorgen dass sie ihre
Verteidigungsfähigkeit erhalten das
gehört Deutschland
Verteidigungsfähigkeit gehört auf jeden
Fall eine Streitkraft die zur
Verteidigung befähigt ist aber dazu
gehört natürlich auch eine
wehrtechnische Industrie die in der Lage
ist die Streitkräfte entsprechend zu
verstärken
Waffenlieferungen an Ukraine ja oder
nein es ist ja eine ganz einfache Sache
also für mich kommen Waffenlieferung
nicht in Frage
liefern sie müssen aber auch bitte zur
Kenntnis nehmen das auch in unserer
Fraktion genau dieses Thema er sehr
kontrovers diskutiert wurde bei der
Abstimmung in deutschen Bundestag es ja
auch Kollegen gegeben hat meiner
Fraktion die für Waffenlieferung
gestellt haben
verstehen
militärischen Hintergrund hat wie würden
sie es machen sie würden keine Waffen in
Ukraine liefern ich würde keine Waffen
in die Ukraine liefern warum nicht um
die weil die Russische Föderation weil
Putin das Potential hat zu eskalieren er
hat das Potenzial soweit sowohl vertikal
zu eskalieren als nuklear macht ja und
um das nicht zu provozieren würde ich
keine Waffenlieferung liefern sondern
früher die Möglichkeit
ergreifen Verhandlung zu init erklären
um zu sagen
es hat Verhandlungen gegeben es ist über
getreideabkommen über über
Gefangenenaustausch und so weiter fahren
hat aber gezeigt dass man miteinander
reden kann wenn man das will ich denke
sie aber ich auf jeden Fall erlebe nicht
dass überhaupt irgendwo der Startschuss
gegeben wird um überhaupt zu verhandeln
um überhaupt den Einstieg zum Ausstieg
zu finden
chinesischen Initiative zum Beispiel
wozu hat das geführt zu nichts
sie meinen die das chinesischen
Präsidenten mit dem russischen Präsident
wie ernsthaft die war kann ich jetzt
nicht beurteilen sie hat zumindest noch
offensichtlich zu keinem Ergebnis
geführt das stimmt es gab ja Angebote
zum Verhandeln
silensky hat sehr deutlich bevor die
kriegsverbrechenden Butcher und ihre PIN
Waren angeboten auf die Krim zu
verzichten internationalen Status für 15
Jahre die besetzten Gebiete von 2014
Russland zu überlassen auf die
NATO-Mitgliedschaft zu verzichten und
die russische Antwort waren Butcher
European mariopol das heißt also all die
Anstrengungen all die Anstrengungen die
die Ukraine selbst unternommen hat und
hat Russland vom Tisch gewischt alle
Gespräche die danach von Amerika mit
Russland geführt wurden hießen nach dem
Motto wir haben schon 20% ihr seid
schwach wir kriegen das ganze Land und
auf diese Fakten müssen sich auch
beziehen es gibt nicht immer nur eine
gute Lösung es gibt manchmal nur eine
schlechte und eine schlechtere noch
schlechtere Lösung und das ist in diesem
Fall für mich der Fall nur eins geht auf
keinen Fall dass er ein Staat wie die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und eine
Regierung der ich immer noch ein wenig
Verantwortungsbewusstsein und der Stelle
die Verteidigungsfähigkeit
des eigenen Landes so vernachlässigt wie
es noch mehr als es vorher in der CDU
geführten Regierung der Fall war er denn
wir müssen an unsere eigenen Interessen
denken das ist eine Verantwortung
zum normal
was haben Sie dort bei diesen Gesprächen
erfahren
ja ich habe die Möglichkeit gehabt zwei
Tage lang Gespräche auf Ministerebene zu
führen und konnte für mich schon sehr
sehr deutlich feststellen dass
es den Ukrainern ernst ist dass sie um
ihren Land kämpfen wollen dass also auch
die
Regierungsmitglieder die Minister
kämpfen wollen und das eine Aufgabe
eines Teils ihres Landes zumindest das
territorialbereich ist wenn man mal die
Krim ausnehmen würde also das Land
Territoriums eine teilweise Aufgabe für
sie nicht in Frage kommt und was löst
das in ihnen aus das löst bei mir aus
dass alle Möglichkeiten
unternommen werden müssen mit Putin zu
verhandeln um auch die Grenzen
aufzuzeigen und auch die die die die die
ja die Möglichkeiten die dann in
Betracht kommen könnten wenn dieser
Krieg sich ausweitet das heißt das sei
so auf die NATO involviert werden würde
ein Szenario dass ich mir nur schwer
vorstellen kann genauso wenig
wie sie höchstwahrscheinlich auch und
ich mir vorstellen kann das mit immer
mehr Waffenlieferung Putin aus der
Ukraine rausgeschmissen werden
im Februar keine Waffen geliefert worden
wären hätten sie die Ukraine im Dezember
nicht mehr besucht das ist ihnen klar
das ist denkbar ja
und das wäre egal oder nein das ist
nicht egal aber wie ich schon eben sagte
es gibt eine schlechte und es gibt eine
noch schlechtere Lösung und eine
Abwägung und wenn ich abzuwägen habe
dann sind für mich die Interessen meines
eigenen Landes die die im Vordergrund
stehen unsere Fragen sind aber auch dass
solche Regelbrüche wie sie von Russland
vorgenommen wurden gegenüber einem
souverän Land wieder Ukraine und
womöglich Taiwan bevorstehen dass unsere
solche Regelbrüche zu verhindern auch in
unserem Interesse ist und eine
Ausweitung des Krieges auch wir müssen
begreifen dass wir Kriegsziel sind und
um nicht Kriegspartei zu werden was wir
werden wenn in Moldau europäische
Staatsbürger betroffen sind nämlich dann
sind wir
Kriegszielen müssen dass wir Kriegsziel
sind dann frage ich sie warum sie in
Kauf nehmen dass die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit Deutschlands
immer mehr meditiert wird das ist doch
Widerspruch völlig falsch was sie sagen
erstens gibt es das 100 Milliarden
Vermögen zweitens gibt es einen sehr
klaren Punkt das jetzt durch den
Austausch eines min dass ich verteidige
die Regierung nicht dass nun endlich
begriffen wird dass diese Regierung von
dem 100 Milliarden Sondervermögen nichts
ausgegeben hat bis Jahresende dass das
meiste der Inflation an heimgefallen ist
und das ist ein planungsverbot gab von
Juli bis Dezember bis Januar für die
deutsche Industrie und der entscheidende
Punkt ist dass wir vertrauen als
Bundesrepublik Deutschland nicht nur in
Polen oder im Baltikum verloren haben
sondern in der Ukraine weil wir nicht
unterstützt haben und der Beweis ist ja
was sie vorwerfen können an der
Bundeswehr dass diese Bundesregierung
verhindert hat dass diese Planung
stattfinden weil weder die Industrie
noch die Bundeswehr vorbereitete
Kampfpanzer hatte
wirklich
den Satz zu Ende bringen entscheidend
ist dass die deutsche Industrie bereits
Ende Februar gesagt hat sie hätten 88
Leo 1 200 Leo 2 diese innerhalb eines
Jahres verfügbar machen könnten
geschehen ist nichts es gab bitten von
Polen und von Spanien tatsächlich
Kampfpanzer zu liefern das hat
Deutschland abgelehnt in der Aussage wir
machen nichts unabgestimmt aber im
Grunde aufgenommen war das eine
Ablehnung und dazu kam dass die
amerikanische Lenkung dass sie jetzt auf
die jetzige Bundesregierung eingehende
ich wirklich nicht in Schutz nehmen
möchte dazu habe ich gar keine
Veranlassung aber es täuscht darüber
hinweg dass eben es sie waren als
Regierung CDU geführte Regierung die die
Bundeswehr in den Zustand gebracht haben
indem wir sie bedauerlicherweise jetzt
vorführen
okay was verstehen Wladimir Putin ist
für Sie was ein kriegsverbreche
ich sag mal das ist jetzt vor den
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
gebracht werden dem übrigen wieder
Russland noch die USA noch China
angehören ist sicherlich eine eine
Möglichkeit hier irgendwann mal ein
Ergebnis zu bekommen
Politikern die nur weil jetzt die
Anklage erhoben worden ist auch
gleichzeitig sagen das schon gefällt das
Urteil warten wir mal aber keins möchte
ich vielleicht auch noch sagen dürfen
Russland keine hin möchten
auch noch sagen dürfen es war unsere
Fraktion unsere Partei die wenige Tagen
nach Kriegsausbruch in ein
Positionspapier eindeutig erklärt hat
dass es sich um ein völkerrechtswidrigen
Angriffskrieg der Russischen Föderation
an und für so etwas
und für so etwas sind deutsche
wehrmachts generale anderthalb Jahre
nach Kriegsende also nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg aufgehängt worden ist doch
schon eine Antwort genug und das andere
ist das dann was der Internationale
Strafgerichtshof entscheidend Steffen
Portrait sag den was ja verständlich
aus dem Bundestag ja
guter Kollege guter Mann
also
wie in jeder Fraktion haben sich die
Kollegen ja nicht ausgesucht sondern sie
sind zusammengekommen sie hatten sich
den nicht ausgesucht ich sag mal mit
seiner
Vorstellung mit der jetzt mit dieser
Situation in der Ukraine umgeht hätte
ich mir nicht
stimmig mit ihm nicht überein und ich
stimme auch seltsamen Auftritte im
russischen properation für habe ich kein
Verständnis ich habe das ja auch mal bei
einem anderen Kollegen sehr sehr
deutlich auch gesagt denn richtig
richtig
denn wir sind in einer Situation es ist
ein Krieg ein Völkerrechts wichtiger
Angriffskrieg und wir als Partei als AFD
als afd-fraktion müssen auch zur
Kenntnis nehmen dass in der deutschen
Bevölkerung dieses Bewusstsein dass es
sich hier um einen Eingriff handelt klar
implementiert ist nicht nur bei mir auch
nicht mit Füßen treten wir können mal
kurz reinhören Steffen Portrait im
russischen Propaganda TV
als Olaf Scholz das erste Mal die Praxis
der großen Kanzler änderte und beschloss
deutsche Panzer für die Teilnahme am
Kampf gegen die russische Armee zu
liefern löste das in Russland eine
ziemlich eindeutige Reaktion aus
gesagt wir befinden uns im Krieg mit
Russland
gehe ich recht in der Annahme dass
Deutschland mit Russland in den Krieg
eingetreten ist und die Beziehung
zwischen unseren Ländern jetzt nicht
anders als ein direkter militärischer
Konflikt bezeichnet werden kann
also das jetzt schwere Waffen schwere
Angriffswaffen geliefert werden das
wollen die Menschen in Deutschland zum
großen Teil nicht
allerdings muss man dazu sagen dass
mehrere Journalisten alles dafür tun
dass die deutsche Bevölkerung gegen
Russland in Stellung gebracht wird
immer noch nicht alle die sehen das
Waffenlieferungen nur kontraproduktiv
sind
und ich bin auch fassungslos dass jetzt
deutsche Waffen wieder dazu geeignet
sind Russen zu töten
der Krieg in der Ukraine ist nicht unser
Krieg
[Musik]
warum macht er das ja das kann ich Ihnen
leider nicht sagen auf jeden Fall
in der Fraktion reden sie über sowas wir
haben in der Fraktion darüber gesprochen
die eine
fraktionsmehrheit auf die der
Fraktionsführung hat sich da für
ausgesprochen dass jeder dort reden kann
wo er es für richtig hält diese
Auffassung bin ich eindeutig nicht ich
halte es für verkehrt in dieser
Situation des Krieges solche Aussagen im
russischen Fernsehen egal ob es nun
Privatsender ist oder nicht es ist
öffentlich also in der russische
Geschäft Propaganda es ist
Öffentlichkeit so wie sie auch
Öffentlichkeit ja
das russisches Propaganda Fernsehen es
ist von mir Wert von mir nicht
akzeptieren sie dann darüber ich meine
kein Wort über die Ukraine ich bin
fassungslos darüber dass Russen getötet
werden von deutschen Panzern
auf ukrainischem Boden in einem Land das
diese Russen überfallen haben naja wenn
ich mich jetzt für ihn erklären sollte
dann kann ich Ihnen sagen das kann ich
nicht machen weil weil ich das einfach
nicht nachvollziehen kann und weil es
auch nicht meiner Auffassung
entspricht okay
sie ist überhaupt nicht gespalten
sondern sie ist pluralistisch und ich
bin sehr stolz darauf der käsewetter
dass wir nicht nur unser Partei sondern
auch in der Fraktion verschiedene
Meinungen zulassen vielleicht auf die
Bescheinigung von kriegsversprechen eine
super bösartige Unterstellung hätte ich
ihn gar nicht zugetraut aber
konzentrieren aber sie haben es eben zu
mir gesagt sie sollen da etwas zurück
das ist nicht ja wir kommen beide aus
einer gleichen Ausbildung und Erziehung
die sollte uns das eigentlich verbieten
nein etwas ich finde Tradition vom 20
Juli 44 und der Freiheitskriege verdient
nicht mir zu unterstellen ist nicht fair
und ist auch unter der Pluralismus
kein Angriff an sie es ist nicht
Pluralismus einer Partei
Kriegsverbrechen zu beschönigen oder
dass ein Eugen Schmidt öffentlich sagt
in Deutschland
im russischen Propaganda Fernsehen
spricht übrigens exzellent russisch
die Deutschen sind einfach noch in einem
Schockzustand viele haben noch nicht
begriffen was auf sie zukommt
die Ersparnisse die die Deutschen haben
und die Deutschen haben bekanntlich
große Sparkonten werden sich in geraumer
Zeit in Nichts auflösen
aber die Regierung profitiert von dieser
Lage das heißt wenn die Einkommen oder
Ersparnisse der Menschen verpuffen ist
das für die Regierung vorteilhaft
die Regierung tut so als ob sie die
Inflation bekämpfen würde aber in
Wirklichkeit ist die Inflation für die
Regierung von Vorteil
und im Moment sehe ich keine ernsthaften
Maßnahmen zur Bekämpfung der Inflation
und deshalb kommt auf die Bevölkerung
ein weiterer wirtschaftlicher Schock zu
und ich bin sicher dass die Proteste die
in Deutschland stattfinden noch ein
Fahrt aufnehmen werden
ich habe mich ja Propaganda Propaganda
Propaganda ich habe mich ja an anderer
Stelle dazu schon mal geäußert und
gesagt wenn eine eine solche
vor das verurteilen der der deutschen
Regierung das Regierungshandeln als
Oppositionspartei in Deutschland in
Berlin vorgenommen wird ist das normal
alles auch eine Aufgabe der
Opposition wenn Sie hier auf Inflation
hinweist wenn man das natürlich in
diesem Kriegszustand in Russland macht
wenn sie sagen auch bei einem Propaganda
Sendung Sender für mich ist allein
öffentlich in Russland macht dann trifft
der Satz zu den ich einmal getroffen
habe man könnte auch zu der Auffassung
gelangen das ist so etwas wie
volksverrat ist
volksverrat ja natürlich er das was den
Zusammenhalt in Deutschland in der in
unserer Republik ermöglicht jetzt preis
zu geben bei jemandem den wir auch als
AFD eine eines völkerrechtswidrigen
Angriffskrieges Anklagen das ist auf
jeden Fall gibt doch das interessant
gibt noch einen anderen Satz von dem
Mann übrigens 75 in Kasachstan geboren
ne Russlanddeutscher deswegen auch
dieses exzellente russisch
da kommt dieser Satz es gibt keine
Demokratie in Deutschland andere
politische Meinungen werden mit allen
möglichen Mitteln unterdrückt sagte in
einem Radiosender mit dem man sitzen sie
in einer Fraktion ja das wissen Sie dass
ich mit ihm in einer Fraktion Sitze
dafür wie halten Sie das aus ich halte
ich halte eine Menge aus wer ist auch
sozusagen sie sagen es ist Landesverrat
haben sie ein anderer Stelle mal gesagt
der die Schwelle zum Landesverrat ist
auch dünn haben sie gesagt das war genau
auf die Rede die sie am Schluss erwähnt
haben ja es gibt keine Demokratie in
Deutschland ich meine
lassen da sitzt ein Typ im Deutschen
Bundestag der sagt es gibt keine
Demokratie in Deutschland der ist
demokratisch gewählt genau der lebt vom
Geld deutscher Steuerzahler und sag es
gibt keine Demokratie in Deutschland ist
doch eine Schande ja ich habe ihn ja
gerade gesagt
an dem Punkt der Moment gekommen und
sagen müsste weißt du was dann ist das
nicht mehr mein Laden nee so weit gehe
ich nicht ähm das entspricht nicht mein
Selbstverständnis sondern ich habe warum
ja ich habe dafür zu kämpfen dass und
ich übernehme jetzt mal ihren begriff
dass der Laden funktioniert
ich habe ihn ja gesagt dass ich dann um
das entspricht meinem Selbstverständnis
in der Partei dafür Sorge dass so etwas
nicht mehr vorkommt wenn ich damit nicht
durchkomme auch eine Partei
pluralistisch ist für mich nicht das
Ergebnis ich verlasse die Partei sondern
ich kämpfe weiter dass diejenigen und
das kann ich Ihnen garantieren immer
noch die Mehrheit darstellen die nicht
für solche Äußerungen sind wie sie sie
gerade von Herrn Schmidt hier zitieren
eindeutig die Mehrheit wir reden Sie mit
ihm darüber
seitdem gar nicht mehr
wer redet noch mit ihm das weiß ich
nicht ich hoffe dass es die fraktions-
und Parteiführung tut die ist dafür auch
zuständig
was würde denn in der CDU Passieren der
Krise weiter wenn einer so reden würde
immer noch mal dieser Satz es gibt keine
Demokratie in Deutschland andere
politische Meinungen werden mit allen
möglichen Mitteln unterdrückt so jemand
wäre gar nicht in der CDU wer sitzt im
Bundestag demokratisch gewählt ist der
Beleg selber der lebende Beleg dafür
dass es Demokratie in Deutschland gibt
weil wir selbst so einen ertragen also
sie nennen das ja selbst Pluralismus der
Punkt ist hat die Fraktion hat ihre
Fraktion die Kraft solche Menschen sie
haben eine Reihe von fraktionslosen
Abgeordneten generiert in den letzten
Jahren so ein Menschen aus der Fraktion
zu bringen das ist die Frage ich kenne
im Auswärtigen Ausschuss seines
Statements dort sind nicht viel anders
wenn entsprechende Fragen erfolgen ich
will nur deutlich sagen sowas ist nicht
tolerabel sie haben sich distanziert
dass er sie aber der Punkt ist dass das
Bild Deutschlands von solchen Menschen
in Russland geprägt wird und das halte
ich schon für sehr bedenklich haben sie
die Kraft
zu bringen
meine Fraktion ist natürlich höchst
bedauerlich wenn allein durch solche
Kollegen das Bild Deutschlands in
Russland geprägt wird ich könnte mir
wünschen dass auch eine andere
Oppositionspartei wie die CDU vielleicht
etwas dafür tut ein positives
Deutschlandbild in der russischen
Förderation gemacht